E aí
[Música]
e eu vou começar pelo princípio e como
No princípio era o verbo vou começar com
o verbo Latino in term ter que quer
dizer criar intervalos é daí que vem a
palavra
intermitência e que é uma tentativa de
expressar uma vivência particular do
tempo eu queria partilhar convosco uma
uma pequena história sobre a qual depois
falarei e que tem uma dimensão de tempo
que me parece interessante uma história
que me foi relatada de um rapaz que se
ocorreu uma pequena Jibóia favor da
Morte e que resolveu adotá-la como seu
animal de estimação
para tu é muito em cima Bem e a jiboia
foi crescendo até mais rápido do que o
próprio rapaz todas as manhãs a jiboia
tinham comportamento singular enquanto o
rapaz se espreguiçava na cama a jiboia
alongava a ver ET aquele ritual todos os
dias o rapaz pensava ela está a imitar
mas estamos cada vez mais próximos algum
tempo depois o animal deixou de se
alimentar e o rapaz Um pouco perturbado
de eu ir ao veterinário
e o veterinário disse então o que a
jiboia está a fazer meu carro rapaz é
medir de todos os dias ela está a
simplesmente à espera de ultrapassar
para te devorar e isso para mim é uma
ótima definição do tempo o tempo é uma
Jibóia que nos meses todos os dias e que
está simplesmente à espera de nos
ultrapassar para nos devorar é like
antes não é
o que me interessa nesta história são
várias dimensões do tempo que ela
contempla um tempo linear a ideia do
crescimento um tempo circular que e com
a ideia de previsibilidade é um ritual
que se repete todos os dias sentimo-nos
Seguros com rituais que repetimos todos
os dias e depois o fator surpresa a
possibilidade que é aquilo que nos dá
alento e nos faz sair da cama todas as
manhãs e enfim basicamente que nós
orientamos a nossa vida com a
linearidade trazendo do passado aquilo
que nos acrescentam alguma coisa que não
se pode ser retirado pedindo que rituais
que nos segure visão e queriam
previsibilidade a procura de uma ideia
de permanência de estabilidade que nos
permita depois enfrentar facilmente a
surpresa e a isso é também um facto na
nossa vida profissional todos nós quando
abraçamos as nossas carreiras
profissionais
ambiência ambicionamos um ambiente de
enorme permanência e estabilidade porque
aí era possível enfrentar desafios
enfrentar novas matérias conhecer mais
coisas aprender mais a E foi exatamente
o desejo dessa estabilidade que
desencadeou em França nos anos 30 um
regime o regime dos assalariados
intermitentes parece ao contrário mas eu
explico nos anos 30 a indústria do
cinema teve um problema muito grande em
França precisava de artesãos que
construíssem os recordes e que ajudassem
a compor o objeto artístico final mas
não havia esses artesãos ou melhor eles
estavam lá mas eles não queriam
trabalhar com o cinema porque o cinema
só lhes dava emprego alguns meses e os
tinham contas para pagar o ano inteiro e
portanto aquele sistema não existe
interessava bom o risco de não haver
cinema francês estão a imaginar o que é
era tão grande que a indústria do cinema
conseguiu pressionar o governo para se
criar uma espécie de regime de cessão o
regime dos assalariados e intermitentes
que permitia que estas pessoas
trabalhassem alguns meses por ano para o
cinema e nos restantes meses recebessem
um salário pago pelo Estado as pessoas
nestas condições foram sendo abrangidas
em regimes mais alargados e
diversificados e são hoje conhecidos
como os intermitentes não são só
artesãos são artistas são técnicos e são
profissionais do espetáculo em
muitíssimas áreas alguns mais visíveis e
outros mais invisíveis em Portugal
escusado será dizer não a regime de
intermitência quer dizer regime É mas
não como uma legislação que proteja a
impermanência os artistas é mais um
estilo de vida eu diria que em Portugal
se nós precisássemos de uma imagem os
artistas os técnicos e os profissionais
na profissionais do espetáculo são um
pouco como aquele rapaz que regressa do
Veterinário com a sua Jibóia e tem de
decidir se mesmo assim depois de ter
aquelas notícias se vai deitar ao lado
dela
mas isto de que falo desta desproteção
social é também uma condição da própria
natureza do trabalho artístico o
trabalho artístico é em si mesmo
intermitente ele é contínuo mas é
invisível os momentos em que ela aparece
são de facto intermitentes e não podia
ser de outra maneira porque nós não
suportaríamos viver confrontados com
obras-primas Jenny a base e estas e
entusiasmo tu tá 24 horas por dia
ninguém aguentaria viver assim em um
artista é capaz de produzir em 8 horas
de trabalho apenas genialidade lamento
informar-vos a muita coisa que vai para
o lixo Então como é que nós fazemos para
antes esta negociação entre estes
momentos de arestas e a necessidade de
estabilidade e permanência nós fazemos
uma coisa muito inteligente organizamos
a nossa vida em rotinas bastante
monótonas bastante repetitivas e abrimos
o espaço de conforto para a novidade E
quando essa novidade aparece sob a forma
normalmente de uma peripécia e um
acontecimento inesperado de uma surpresa
de uma revira-volta
acontecem as histórias o nosso cérebro
que é extremamente viciado em novidade
ao contrário de algumas pessoas serve
que não tem se for novidade ele adora
Doyle dados novos e usados para tentar
encontrar caminhos novos para resolver
integrar esses dados e vai produzindo
histórias hora nós desde o princípio dos
tempos não fazemos mais do que contar
histórias uns aos outros é assim que Nós
criamos a identidade é assim teríamos
comunidades e assim que criamos também
uma história comum Aliás o escritor
Afonso Cruz diz que mais do que ossos e
órgãos e admi moléculas nós somos mesmo
é feito de histórias
e por isso mesmo vou contar-vos mais uma
história a história dos Canários nas
minas de carvão
em 1986 foi finalmente proibido a que os
mineiros se fizessem acompanhar de um
canário para dentro das minas de carvão
E faziam-no desde o final do século 19
porque era um metro de proteção bastante
infalível a tinha sido percebido que as
grandes explosões que ocorriam dentro
das minas eram provocadas por grandes
concentrações de monóxido de carbono e
os pássaros são muito sensíveis a esse
gás que é tão traiçoeiro ele tal então
os mineiros transportavam uma pequena
gaiola curvados para dentro da mina é
uma um pássaro a e eram guiados pelo seu
canto se o pássaro se o seu
comportamento se alterasse ele parasse
de cantar os mineiros sabiam que estava
na hora de procurar a saída mais próxima
Isto é particularmente importante a
quando havia explosões tremor de terra e
exatamente havia Suspensões e todos
ficavam à espera do movimento destes
pássaros é porque eu contei esta
história o Jorge Luis Borges tem uma uma
uma situação que diz que a arte é uma
espécie de espelho nós próprios para mim
esta história é um espelho daquilo que
se passa entre os artistas e os comuns
Mortais já terão percebido que para mim
os canários são os artistas e os
mineiros somos todos nos comuns Mortais
um pouco mais cinzentos talvez cobertos
de pó atarefados com o nosso dia a dia
mas estes mineiros que somos nós não se
podem extrair dos Canários de maneira
nenhuma eo canto dos Canários não pode
ser para eles uma distração o canto dos
Canários é que o que distingue a vida da
Morte e quando temos uma história muito
curta sobre como a arte distingue mesmo
a vida da morte a uma escritora
Argentina Graciela Cabal que diz que o
seu pai que estava no hospital já
bastante mal cada vez que recebi a
visita do médico Oi filha dizia que ele
teria muito pouco tempo de vida dizia
não não não não pode ser eu ainda não
acabei de ler o meu livro e assim que o
médico virava as costas ele pedia que
lhe trouxessem um novo livro cada vez
mais espessos para tardar esse momento
Então esse o canto dos Canários pode
ajudarmos a distinguir este momento
entre a vida EA morte eu gostava de vos
perguntar quando é que foi a última vez
que eu ouviram cantar muito obrigada
G1
[Aplausos]